hey Texas so when we say southern-style
barbecue it's a lot of different regions
that have very specific styles right but
in general the main thing you gotta know
is all [ __ ] delicious all-you-can-eat
Korean barbecue you get like a lot of
like side dishes and stuff so like I
feel like the main focus for this is
like the meat I'm vegetarian
so I'm just going to be eating
everything but the meat I'm you know I'm
hungry ready for it see I get so turned
on by meat fat sausage these are hot
legs okay I feel like it's gonna it's
not gonna be that spicy the skin is
really tough which I'm not used to what
are you used to like yeah condoms are
supposed to be like soft and chewy this
is kind of crunchy oh that's good yeah
yeah that's actually pretty spicy I'm
impressed
they're not like super spicy as a Korean
person like I haven't used to like super
spicy food yeah I approve of this this
is good oh you like it yeah yeah all
right we're gonna go to the brisket now
as a texan brisket is for me where it's
at do you want some of this
oh okay thank you what's a brisket it's
a cow chess cow pecks like her you just
look like a piece of bark that's
elephant treat into it Cuddy you can
have that okay I love it
I'm enjoying this I'm afraid to open my
mouth max I have like a piece of me
right definitely gotta bring my sauce
for this we put barbecue sauce to some
barbecue styles come with sauce butter
on top and some come with on the side
I'm gonna Texas so I do it from the side
from what I understand then you've never
had barbecue ribs feel like I've had
some from like Outback Steakhouse oh no
I feel like the true test of this is how
well the meat falls off the bone oh it
just comes right off that's a good thing
right
yeah that's a great sign mmm that looks
so good it's so good you animal this is
right this is pig meat right
cow no Pig you either yeah like love
that first bite like doesn't look really
good
that's really very good oh my god no
just leave this here on your plate that
pork rib is perfectly sized and that fat
on it it's just mmm
can't get better than that pork fat this
is delicious but I don't think anything
compares to any barbecue there's
definitely good enough to eat more than
once here's the thing in the world
southern United States barbecue and
Korean barbecue I request you gather
around like the pit or the grill and you
have like a cookout or smoke out and you
have all the like neighborhood people
gather it's like more than just cuisine
it's a tradition look you're still going
for it yeah so your lunch